- I never stood at the
beginning of my journey
thinking I'm going to be an entrepreneur.
I stood at the beginning
of my journey thinking
I actually can't work for anybody.
I hear a lot said about passion.
Passion is absolutely brilliant,
but being passionate too early
can be a very, very dangerous thing.
You know, I think the downs
are as important in life
as the ups but it's how
you handle those downs.
- She's an English business woman who ran
a multi-million dollar
family holiday business.
She's now best known for her appearances
on BBC's Dragons' Den.
She has an estimated net
worth of 40 million pounds.
She's Deborah Meaden,
and here's my take on her
top ten rules for success.
Rule number nine is my personal favorite.
And make to stick around
all the way until the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always if Deborah says something
that really inspires you
please leave it in the comments below.
And put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
(wind whooshes)
(booms)
(dramatic instrumental music)
(beeps)
- I never stood at the
beginning of my journey
thinking I'm going to be an entrepreneur.
I stood at the beginning
of my journey thinking
I actually can't work for anybody.
So my only real choice was to actually
set up in business on my own.
And then I learnt through
my business experience
that actually I enjoyed the
moments of yes we did it.
And I actually oddly enjoyed
the really difficult moments
where you think oh what have
I done what have I done?
Because what entrepreneurs do, do is that
they don't see barriers,
they do see 'round them.
It's amazing the amount of
entrepreneurs that I know
that are dyslexic and I
believe that's because
they've always had to think around things.
They've had to find a
different way to do things
and that is something
an entrepreneur does.
One of the things I was
asked to talk about today
is some of the barriers
that I've come across.
Do you know I don't think I have.
And I obviously have but
it's kind of part of life.
It's what you do as an entrepreneur.
You get a problem you look
at it and you talk to people.
And you walk around a bit.
And you think oh, that's
how you can solve that.
And then you move on you don't stand there
for hours thinking, oh,
wasn't that difficult
and didn't we do well
you just get on with it.
And for me that is a really,
really important part
of when you're running a
business 'cause you know.
We all know it can get
really, really tough.
- [Interviewer] Do you think that
people should go for something
that they feel comfortable with?
- Definitely, I think in
business it's really important
well I think to be good at something
you have to enjoy it, you have to love it.
But the truth is I'm
sure there's many things
that I didn't know I was
going to enjoy dancing,
I didn't discover that 'til I was 55.
So there's many things in
life that you can enjoy,
but if you do find something
then that sets you on your way.
It sets you on good stead
if you actually like
the thing you're doing.
Don't fool yourself be
absolutely honest and clear
over your idea.
Is it a good idea, is it a bad idea?
Why am I doing it, what is my motivation?
This is essential in every walk in life
but it's absolutely
crucial for entrepreneurs.
I can remember times in my business life
where I've actually done things
because I wanted to do them.
I had to convince myself
that it was a brilliant idea simply
because I wanted to do it.
And there's a world of difference between
actually taking a cool
critical look at what it is
you're about to do and
then getting passionate.
I hear a lot said about passion.
Passion is absolutely brilliant,
but being passionate too early
can be a very, very dangerous thing.
I'm going to say something
else about business
and I think it's the most important thing
that I have learnt.
Before you start your business
or in your early days think
about why you're doing it.
Everybody in this room will
have a different reason.
And if it is just to make
money you're a business person.
If it's because of something else
if it's because of a passion
if it's because you've seen something
that you really, really want to do
and you've got a burning desire to do it,
that tips you into being an entrepreneur.
Because being in business is more.
No, I'm going to put this
a different way business
is about creating the thing for you
that you want you want out of your life.
And it's that old adage
of am I working to live,
or am I living to work?
And business is your
tool to create that life.
The trouble is as we get into business,
as business gets bigger and as it grows,
we can forget that.
We get forget the reason
we started in the first place
and we can get completely overcome
with all of the issues
and the problems that we have.
So before you start
or at the very early stages
of your journeys think to yourselves
why am I doing this?
What is my motivation?
And write yourself a letter
because in those tough and hard times
when we've all had them.
When we all think
I cannot believe I've
gotten myself into it,
that is the letter you need to get out.
And you need to remember.
And also you need to remember in the times
when your customers are looking at you
in a very confused way saying,
"I don't recognize you anymore.
"You're not what you told me you were."
You need to get that letter out again
and you need to see the
promises you've made to yourself
and you need to see the promises
you've made to your letter.
Oh, to your letter, to your customers.
- [Interviewer] You've
had your downs as well as
very substantial ups didn't you?
- Well, you know I think the downs are
as important in life as the ups.
But it's how you handle those downs.
The downs never stopped me
the downs made the think
mm, didn't like that failing.
I really don't like that feeling.
What do I learn from it?
And therefore what do I
go on and do differently?
- Rather than it knocking you out,
it inspired you to have another go did it?
- Absolutely do you know oddly
I think the disliking the downs outweighed
the enjoying the highs.
So I kind of focus more on
I don't want to do that
again I want to get it right.
Another critical point is research.
It is so important to understand
as much as you can about the
market you're about to enter
if you're going to minimize risk.
Yes, being an entrepreneur
is about taking risks
but you can minimize that risk by fully
understanding what you're about to do.
That involves market research,
understanding your customer,
knowing what the market's all about.
Where I'm going to get the products from.
It's all the research that you
should identify very, very early on.
What do I need to know?
In addition to that,
you also need to know the
numbers that you need to know.
So it's no good just
guessing well you know
there's probably a few
million people out there
who'll probably buy the product.
Make sure you're very specific.
Come up with list, the key information
you need to find out go and find out
and don't make your decision to enter
that market until you've
got all of that information.
- [Host] I like the line
and I think this is great,
that I'm not always nice
but I'm always fair.
Yeah, I mean I get I can be
quite tough and I know that.
But to be honest I could
for the populist vote,
I know what people will want me to say.
I know the nice thing to say
but actually I think it's quite unkind
to lead people to believe
that they should carry on with something
that actually is going to fail.
So I think I'm doing my job and I think
I'm doing the right thing
by saying don't do that.
- Over all that very thumbnail sketch
of a very interesting and
a very inspiring life,
what do you think you've learnt most?
I mean what would you do
differently in other words?
- Do you know, I wouldn't
do anything differently
because I think getting things wrong is,
as we've just talked
about getting things wrong
is as important as getting things right.
So I wouldn't change anything
because actually I have learnt a lot.
And the thing that I've learnt is
I know what I value in life.
I know what's important to me.
I know what I want to spend my time doing.
I know the differences
that I want to make.
And, more important I absolutely know
what I don't want to do.
I mean role models are
really, really important.
I could name you a lot
of people I meet everyday
and some of them are
people I'm invested in.
Some of the people I've
worked alongside with
you wouldn't know any of them.
Because when I walk through life
what I've realized is nobody has it all.
And when we look at role models
we tend to think that's it
that's the person I want to be.
Trust me however many times Evan says
I'm the expert in everything, I'm not.
Nobody has it all.
But what I do realize is people in life
that I meet do something extraordinary
and I think that was brilliant.
That was fantastic and I
pick up that information,
I put it in my tool box.
And when I need it I'll remember,
I'll go back to them and I'll think
that was brilliant.
So my role models don't have names.
They have moments and experiences
and there are people who
I could just roll off
and you'd think who's she talking about?
And that's my tip to you.
Don't look for that in one person
that you can say that's who I want to be.
Look across the range and
think that's the moment,
that's the person,
that's the person I want.
I remember that, I remember
how they dealt with that.
- [Interviewer] Who
would get the most money
if tables were turned and you had
to pitch an idea in the den?
(whimsical music)
(buzzer)
- Let me guess.
- Don't say you said Deborah.
- (mumbles)
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Who is the
most stubborn in the den?
(ping)
(laughs)
- We actually agreed.
- [Interviewer] Who looks
more intimidating in the den?
(ping)
- I hesitated but I probably do sadly.
- [Interviewer] Who is more likely
to team up with another
dragon for an investment?
- Yeah, yeah I'd say
that's a fair one, yeah.
- Did we go (mumbles).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Who has
the best working wardrobe?
(ping)
- Yee!
- [Interviewer] Which of you
is the stingiest in the den?
(exhales loudly)
(laughs)
- Neither where's my neither paddle?
- I think that's fair did you go neither?
I wouldn't say either
of us are stingy we're just competitive.
- We're just very generous
big hearted people.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Who makes
the flashiest purchases?
- Oh.
(ping)
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Who takes the longest
in hair and makeup on set?
(buzzer)
(laughs)
- Oh shut up!
- To be fair I was lying.
I definitely take longer than Peter.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Who has had
the most successful investment
since the den started?
(buzzer)
(laughs)
- Just Google it.
(chuckles)
Can we have on more question
(mumbles) like this?
- [Interviewer] Who is more likely
to get their investment chosen
against Duncan Bannatyne?
- Oh either both.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Great,
thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
I Amit Arora asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the clips meant the most to you.
What did Deborah say that
really left it's mark on you?
Leave it in the comments I'm
going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Torsten Kuehn, I hope
I pronounced that okay.
Torsten, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, it really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourselves, and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(wind whooshes)
(booms)
- My career, my business
love of my life really.
The last time I worked in a
business was Weststar Holidays.
And Weststar Holidays
by the time I sold it
we were providing about
200000 holidays a year.
And I loved that business,
I absolutely lived, ate, and breathed it.
And actually I almost
would have felt disloyal
to go on and run another
business, I really loved it.
I was asked to talk about IP today.
And I thought well actually in Weststar,
in the traditional terms
you wouldn't necessarily
have considered the IP of that business.
But of course there's
IP in everything you do.
Everybody thinks of IP
as you've seen me on Dragons' Den.
You know, I have to look at the patterns.
I can't help myself.
Patterns, trademarks, all of those things.
But actually IP is much more than that
and protection of that IP
is much more than that.
There is the legal protection.
Is this important to protect it?
Is it protect-able?
Does it actually matter?
That's the legal side of it.
But there is also the brand protection.
The things that Cobra Beer
has done so brilliantly.
They made this wonderful thing.
I just know they would protect that
to the ends of the Earth.
What does Cobra Beer mean, nobody
is going to take that away from them.
So that whole thing it's not
just about legal protection.
What really matters to this business?
Why do the customers really like me?
And I'm not going to move away from that
because I know that's
what my customers want.
And as businesses get bigger
we can sometimes lose that.
We can sometimes forget what
it is that out customers want
and we kind of think,
oo should we try a new.
Well we've done that
let's try something else.
And before you know it
you're doing something
completely different.
And your customers are looking at you
and kind of,
"Weren't you the people
who promised me that?
"And you're over here somewhere."
So that is the whole
protection of what you are
and who you are is really, really
for me, very, very important.
Important to be able to
stay cool under pressure.
Now this obviously is when you enter
the den that's very important
because you've got to
get your message across
but that is so in business life.
Because if you can't stand up
to the pressure in the den,
trust me you are not going
to be able to stand up
to the pressures that
actually happen out there
in real business life.
So remember to do whatever
it is that you've got to do
to prepare yourself to make sure
that you do not crumble under pressure.
- What are your favorite rules
do you have any favorite rules?
- The one that I do keep banging on about
is I hear so often people saying
keep in touch with your customer.
You know the customer's king
or the customer's really important
and then they completely ignore them.
And it's just to me so obvious.
Watch your customer,
respond to your customer.
They're changing all the time,
I'm a different person
today than I was last year.